[موسيقى]
طبتم ما طابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى هذه
النشره الاخباريه المفصله من العربيه
ونبداها بابرز العناوين
في الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه تقدموا
الجمهوريه بمجلس النواب ومنافسه حاده على
مجلس الشيوخ
نسكافيه
اوكرانيا يتحدثون عن معارك عنيفه في
ميكولايت
ايرانيون يدعون للتظاهر لاحياء مجزره
زهدان ومقتل عنصر بالباسيج خلال عمليه
اعتقال محتجين
المرصد السوري يعلن مقتل 15 عنصرا من
ميليشيات مواليه لايران في قصف بشرق سوريا
حياكم الله
يتواصلوا فرزوا اصوات الناخبين في
الانتخابات النصفيه للكونغرس الامريكي
ووفقا للنتائج الاوليه حصد الديمقراطيون
على اربعه على ثمانيه واربعين مقعدا مقابل
47 مقعد للجمهوريين حتى الان في انتخابات
مجلس الشيوخ ياتي هذا بعد انتزاع
الديمقراطيه جون فترمان مقعدا حاسما ضد
محمد اوز المدعوم من ترامب في ولايه
بنسلفانيا وعلى الصعيدي النتائج انتخابات
مجلس النواب فان الجمهوريين حسموا
195 مقعدا مقابل
للديمقراطيين حتى الان
من جانبه قال الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب بان الجمهوريين يتفوقون في
عدد من الولايات بالفوارق جيده على
الديمقراطيين وهم يبلون جيدا في انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه
وهذا قد يكون مستبعدا الجمهوريون يتفوقون
في عدد من الولايات بفوارق جيده ونحن نبلي
جيدا في الانتخابات حتى اللحظه ونتوقع
نتائج رائعه للجمهوريين في الانتخابات
النصفيه
كانت محتدمه في ولايه
بعض وسائل الاعلام الحاضره شككت بقدره
الجمهوريين على الفوز
قبل ذلك اكد النائب الجمهوريه كيفن مكارثي
ان الجمهوريين سيستعيدون السيطره على مجلس
النواب فيما بداتها موجه مد المحفظين في
انتخابات منتصف الولايه في الولايات
المتحده محدوده اكثر من ما كان متوقعا
افادت وسائل واعلام الامريكيه بانتخاب
الجمهوريه اجاي ديفانس الذي يدعمه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب عضو في مجلس الشيوخ
عن ولايه اوهايو في اول خيبه امل كبيره
للرئيس الديمقراطي في الانتخابات منتصف
الولايه وفاز ديفانس على الديمقراطيه
مرايا بمقعد كان يشغله جمهوريه وتوريكا
فاز الديمقراطيه جون فترمان بمقعد في
ولايه بنسلفانيا ذات الاهميه الكبيره في
الانتخابات النصفيه وواجهها فترمان الذي
كان يتعافى من جلطه دماغيه اصيب بها في
مايو المرشح الجمهوري محمد اوز في واحده
من اكثر المعارك التنافسيه في انتخابات
منتصف الولايه وقال بيتر مان لقد رحنا على
سكان بنسلفانيا ولم يخدمونا لن اخذه لكم
مشيرا الى ان هذا سباق الانتخابي يعكس
نضال سكان الولايه وصفه
يا عمري توقعاتنا اوليه ان حكيمه ولايه
فلوريدا الجمهوريه رون
ديسانتسا الذي يعد مرشح محتملا للرئاسه
عام 2024 سيكون احد الفائزين الاوائل في
انتخابات منتصف الولايات الولايات المتحده
واشارت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه الى فوزه
على منافسه الديمقراطيه
كريستال ليستمر في منصبه حاكما لولايه
للولايات عفوا لولايه الثانيه في فلوريدا
ويعزز صعود بشكل بارز في الحزب الجمهوري
مع طموحات محتمله في الوصول الى البيت
الابيض
ينظر الكثيرون الى الانتخابات التشديد
النصفي هذا العام على انها حاسمه بالنسبه
للمستقبل السياسي للرئيس الحالي جوبايدن
والسابق دونالد ترامب الانتخابات تمثلون
نقطه تمهدوا للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
التي غالبا ما ستجمع ترامب من جديد
[موسيقى]
ودونالد ترامب وضع بيضهما في سله
الانتخابات النصفيه ورهنا بكل مستقبلهم
السياسي في هذا الموعد حمله شرسه ركزت على
التضخم قادها الجمهوري الذين ظهروا واثقين
اكثر من اي وقت مضى من فرصه في تجريد من
غالبيته الديمقراطيه في الكونغرس
الرئيس
يمنحه نقطه انطلاق مثاليه للترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد عامين من الان
وهو الهدف الاسم لترامب الذي يرغب في
العوده الى البيت الابيض من جديد
مقابل الرئيس الحالي الذي سعى للحفاظ على
تفوقه من خلال كسب الاصوات من اليسار
والوسط عبر تصوير المعارضه الجمهوريه على
انها تهديد للديمقراطيه والمكتسبات
الاجتماعيه في وقت بدت فيه جهوده للظهور
على انه رئيس الطبقه الوسطى لم تعطي نتيجه
المرجوه
انتخابات نصف الولايه التي تجر بعد عامين
من الانتخابات الرئاسيه تمثل استفتاء على
الرئيس الحالي ملايين الدولارات انفقت على
هذه المنافسات ما جعل منها انتخابات نصف
الولايات الاغلى في تاريخ امريكا ومن
خلالها تبدا خارطه الولايات تتكسف بخصوص
الرئاسيات المقبله بلال الوجداني العربيه
[تصفيق]
معنى من بيروت المحلل السياسي الدكتور بول
مرقص دكتور اهلا بك هل بكى يوم الخامس عشر
من نوفمبر
حالي موعدا لاعلان ترامب بانيته خوض
انتخابات الرئاسه مجددا طالما ان الوضع
حتى الان في صالح الجمهوريين على الاقل
اساسا ان هذا الحلم يراود الرجل منذ ان
ترك الولايه الرئاسيه بنهايه وهو فعل كل
شيء من اجل النجاح تعرف معي انا محاوله
الاتصال بحكام الولايات شكك بنداء
الانتخابات
ارسل مناصره لاقتحام الكابتل الى ما هنالك
همم ايضا ثابر على انتقاد الرئيس الحالي
بسبب التضخم بسبب مساله الحدود بسبب الملف
الاخراني الاجهاض همم كل ذلك مع ارتفاع
معدلات الفائده بحسب الفدر الاحتياطي
فيدرالي مقابل ركود في الاتصال في
المواضيع الصحيه ايضا كل ذلك نعم يجعل منه
طبعا مرشح الرئاسيا بطبيعه الحال ايضا همم
الرئيس الحالي ربما سيكمل ولايته طبعا اذا
فاز الجمهوريون في مجلس الشيوخ ايضا سيكمل
الو اهو ضعيفا اكثر مما هو اساسا وبالتالي
فان هذا النظام الرئاسي الهمم موجود في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لن يكون بوسع
همم رئيسه ام يستعمل صلاحياته بسهوله مع
تعكير صفو هذه الصلاحيات في المجلسين من
حيث التمويل والميزانيه وتعيين القضاه
والاتفاقيات الدوليه والسياسه الخارجيه
التي ايضا يقبض عليه همم مجلس همم
الكونجرس بمجلسه همم بالتوازن مع الرئيس
وهذا ما يسمى في الولايات المتحده تشاكس
ام بلد يعني حتى الان في مجلس الشيوخ
النتائج الاوليه تشير الى تقدم وادي
الديمقراطيين هل ننتظر ربما مفاجاه خاصه
انه لبعض يتحدث من انه التصويت الذي سبق
يوم الاقتراع قد يصب في صالح الديمقراطيين
فبالتالي قد يكون اقوياء همم كما هم
ويحتفظون بمقاعدهم ولا ربما اكثر
اعتقد ان سمكه ثلاث ولايات حاسمه شانها
شان بنسلفانيا التي حسمت في الساعه
الحاضره وبالتالي ان مساله هذه الولايات
مساله كثيره الدقه في تحديد الاجابه
المطلوبه لكن بالعموم استطيع ان اقول ان
تم تتقاربا كثيرا في عدد من الولايات مما
يستدعي وفقا القانون الانتخابي الامريكي
لانه قائم على النظام الاكثري كما تعرف
اعاده الفرز وربما ايضا اعاده الانتخابات
يعني المساله لن تكون بالسهوله بالتمام
والكمال كما ننتظر نحن في انتخابات على
دائره واحده مثلا كما في دولنا وبالتالي
هذه مجموعه من الدول مجموعه من الولايات
تحتاج الى فرز اصوات دقيق بسبب هذا
التقارب دكتور بيقول ارجو ان تبقى معي
سنستعرض بعض النتائج ومن ثم نعود لاستكمال
الحديث
اجي اظهرت منافسه حاده في مجلس الشيوخ حيث
هنا للحزب الديمقراطي 48 مقعدا حتى اللحظه
مقابل 47 للحزب الجمهوري بعد انتزاع
الديمقراطي جون فطر من مقعدا حاسما في
مجلس الشيوخ ضد محمد اوز المؤيد من ترامب
في ولايه بن سلفانيا ويتبقى خمسه مقاعد
فقط في ولايات الاسكا اريزونا جورج
جانيفادا وسكينسون وعلى صعيدي نتائج
انتخابات مجلس النواب حصد الجمهوريين على
193 مقعدا مقابل 166
للديمقراطيين وحتى الان
يتبقى همم 76 مقعدا فيما اكد زعيم
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب انه من الواضح
ان حزبه سيحقق كل الاغلبيه
معنى من بيروت ان نعود الى الدكتور
يعني اليوم هل نقول وداعا نانسي بيلوسي
وبالتالي اهلا بزعيم الاقليه السابقه
والمرشح الجديده ربما
نعم ما هذا امر مرجح ولكن ايضا من يعني
الضروري القول ان السياسه
بمعناها العضوي يعني ستتغير في مجلسي
الكونغرس اعتقد اننا سنشهد نصف ولايه صعبه
بالنسبه للرئيس الامريكي بسبب المشكلات
التي ذكرتها لكن ايضا بسبب يعني همم
استفحال الحمله عليه طبعا من قبل الرئيس
ترامب وهمم مناصري الحزب الجمهوري الذي
بالطبع فاز يعني اليوم نستطيع ان نقول انه
فاز لكن المساله ليست حاسمه مثلا همم في
همم مجلس الشيوخ لكنه فاز بيتقدم كبير في
الولايات معينه ادت الى اعاده احكام
السلطه من قبله همم على المستوى الباروني
التحدث وبالتالي ستزيد هذه الامور تعقيدا
على الرئيس الحالي
يعني اليوم حينما نتحدث عن بعانه والاخر
من قضيه ال- ال- العزل التي كان ينظر
اليها في اخر ولايته اليوم هل سيتكرر ذات
الامر مع بايدن هل سيكون الجمهوريون اكثر
عده من الديمقراطيين تجاه السنتين
المقبلتين
راسيين هم يعني سوف
ت تعبير في المعنى السياسي بينما
الجمهوريون خصوصا مع قياده الصقور لترامب
هم همم بمعنى انهم يعني لا يرافون في
المعركه السياسيه وبالتالي يذهبون الى همم
تحطيم سوره الخصم وهذا ما ثابر عليه
الرئيس الامريكي بتصوير السابق ترامب
تصوير الرئيس حالي على انه ضعيف وبالفعل
فان سياسته في عدد من الميادين التي
ذكرتها اظهر هذا الضعف خصوصا اخيرا بالملف
الاوكراني الذي قال فيه الرئيس ترامب انه
لو كان هو الرئيس لكان حسنه على طاوله
المفاوضات ونعرف انه من الناس الذين
يحسمون ولديه من الهيبه في السياسه
الخارجيه ومن التقارب المريض همم
اذا اردت القول مع الرئيس الروسي بما
يجعلنا هذا الملف ربما كان انتهى على
طاوله المفاوضات اضف الى ذلك مساله ابن
الرئيس بيضا حاليا الذي يتهم بالملف الا
يعني فبالتالي نعم هذه الصعوبات ستزداد في
النصف الاخير من الولايه الرئاسيه الحاضره
خصوصا مع التقدم الجمهوري وخصوصا مع البطئ
في المعالجه التي حاول القيام بها الرئيس
بايدا ولم يفلح الى حدود كبيره بما يشفي
خليل الامريكيين في موضوعات ساخنه خصوصا
ب- بمنى التحتيه بموضوع الصحه بموضوع همم
التضخم الاسعار موضوعات اجتماعيه همم لم
اكرر ان الاجهاض واحده منها الى ما هنالك
من مسائل لم تكن الروايه الرئاسيه في
نصفها الاول حاسمه بشان هذه الملفات
شكرا للدكتور الدكتور بول مرقص من بيروت
كنت معنا شكرا جزيلا
تاتي الانتخابات النصفيه للكونغرس
الامريكيه في ظروف خاصه تمر بها الولايات
المتحده ما يجعل هذه الجوله مؤثره بشكل
كبير ليس فقط على مقاعد الكونجرس بل على
الحياه السياسيه للبلاد في قادم السنوات
انتخابات لتجديد نصف مقاعد الكونغرس
الامريكيه بل هي لحظه في الحياه السياسيه
للولايات المتحده فلنتائجها واقعون كبير
على المستقبل القريب لامريكا
ريح تغيير ان هبت فانها ستطال اولا سياسات
جوبايدن خلال السنتين المتبقيتين له في
ولايته فاجندته قد تواجه بعض العراقيل كما
ان المسار الديمقراطي على المحاك سيا ما
في ظل تعالي خطاب التشكيك في نزاهه
الانتخابات من طرف مناصرها الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب وهو ما يعني
ان الانتخابات الحاليه هي امتحان
للديمقراطيه فاما اعاده الاعتبار للمشهد
الديمقراطي في البلاد او تكريس الشكوك
التي تتزايد شيئا فشيئا من شان الانتخابات
الحاليه ان تلقي بظلالها ايضا على
العمليات الانتخابيه المقبله على المدى
المتوسط والقريب حيث قد يعمل فريق
الجمهوريين بشكل خاص على بلوره افكار
لاعاده تشكيل الدوائر الانتخابيه وتغيير
الاجراءات الانتخابيه على مستوى الولايات
عامل المهيمن اخرج على الانتخابات النصفيه
ذات اهميه خاصه فهي تعد مؤشرا حقيقيا لرسم
خريطه حظوظ المرشحين للرئاسيات القادمه
سواء تعلق الامر بالرئيس الحالي بعدنا او
السابق ترامب او غيرهما فهي وحده لقياس
مدى شعبيه كل حزب وقدرته على جذب اصوات
النخبه وسام الذهبي العربي
الفاصل
انا في تسلا بنحو 4 مليارات دولار بعد
استحوا به على تويتر
حياكم الله قالت محافظه مدينه
نيويورك الامريكيه كثيره
قراراتهن المختلفه
الله وبركاته
الكامله ويعيشون في مجتمعات دون خوف
التمتع بالاماني للتجول في الشوارع وركوب
قطارات الانفاق دون تواجد الاسلحه غير
القانونيه وسيصبح مكانا تتم فيه حمايه
الحقوق الاساسيه ويمكن للنساء
الخاصه
الذي يعتلينا هنا اليوم قد تحطم اخيرا في
ولايه نيويورك وانتم حققتم ذلك
حقق اول مرشحا من الجيل زد الفوز بمقعدا
في مجلس النواب الامريكي عن الحزب
الديمقراطي الشاب ماكسويل فروستا البالغ
من العمر 25 عاما اصلا افريقي يعتبر اول
عضو في الكونغرس الامريكيين ينتمي الى جيل
زد وفاز على الجمهوريه
بعد فتره وجيزا من اغلاق الصناديق
الاقتراع غرد فروست على تويتر بخبر فوزي
قائلا انه تم صنع التاريخ لسكان فلوريدا
وللجيل زد يذكر ان الجيل الجديد ياتي بعد
جيل الالفيه وهم مواليد الفتره ما بين
منتصف التسعينيات ومنتصف العقد الاول من
الالفيه الثانيه
هكذا زعيم الجمهوريين بمجلس النواب كيفما
كارتي ان جمهوريين سيستعيدون سيطره على
مجلس النواب مشيرا الى ان الجمهوريين
عملوا طيله العامين الماضين على تلبيه
طموحات الامريكيين وكانت النتيجه دعم
الملايين من جميع انحاء البلاد
[تصفيق]
وين بالضبط
[موسيقى]
لما اتوقع ابدا اننا سنحول هذه المقاطعه
الحمراء الى اللون الازرق لكننا فعلنا ما
احتجنا الى القيام به واجرينا تلك
النقاشات كل واحده من تلك المقاطعات
والليله ساكون السيناتور القادم من
بنسلفانيا
ولم يخدمونها لن اخذ لكم بتاتا
فزت نشطه والمحاميه الديمقراطيه كاتي هوش
هول بمنصب حاكم ولايه نيويورك على منافسها
الجمهوريه لزيدان المدعوم من ترامب فوزه
ان يجعلها اول امراه تنتخب لهذا المنصب
الذي تولته عام 2021 عقب استقاله الحاكم
السابق اندرو كوم ويعتبر فوز هوشه المتوقع
ان في ولايه يبلغ عدد الديمقراطيين فيها
المسجلين اكثر من ضعف الجمهوريين
الى الملف الاوكرانيه الروسيه حيث قال
الجيش الاوكراني انه اسقطها 9 طائره مسيره
روسيه في ما اكد تنفيذ 18 غاره جويه
استهدف استهدفت مواقع عسكريه وانظمه
صواريخ مضاده للطائرات من جانبه اكد رئيس
بلديه
روسيا ان القتال العنيف مستمر في المنطقه
بدوره قال نائب رئيس الاداره الروسيه في
منطقه
القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت التقدم على ثلاث
جبهات من هذه البلديه في الاثناء
الحاكم الاوكراني لمنطقه ميكو لايف الى ان
القوات الاخرانيه طردت القوات الروسيه من
المنطقه
تعهد الرئيس الاوكرانيه بلودميرازيلنسكي
بالا تتخلق قوته عن سنتيمتر واحد في
المعارك الدائره للسيطره على منطقه دونيسك
الشرقيه مشيرا الى ان القوات الروسيه تنفذ
عشرات الهجمات كل يوم شرقيه اوكرانيا
زلنسكي اكد ايضا ان القوات الروسيه تتكبد
خسائر كبيره للغايه موضحا ان الكهرباء
انقطعت عن نحو اربعه ملايين شخص في اربع
اشرطه بالاضافه الى العاصمه كيف
وفي رساله مصوره عرضت في مؤتمر المناخ في
كوب 27 المنعقد في مصر اكد الرئيس زيننسكي
ان الحرب في اوكرانيا اثرت بدورها على
المناخ بسبب ازمه الطاقه كما قال ان
الهجمات الروسيه تسببت في تدمير الغابات
في اوكرانيا
حتى يرى العالم ما يمكننا فعله معنا
لانقاذ انفسنا من كارثه
تسببت الحرب الروسيه في ازمه طاقه اجبر
عشرات الدول على استئناف توليد الطاقه
التي تعمل بالفحم من اجل خفض اسعار طاقه
لشعوبها كما جلبت الحرب الروسيه ازمه
غذائيه حاده للعالم ودمرت خمسه ملايين
فدان من الغابات في اوكرانيا في اقل من
سته اشهر
غضب شعبي عارم ما شهدته مدينه الروسيه
بالقرب من الحدود الاوكرانيه نتيجه
الخسائر الفادحه في صفوف ابنائها الذين
قتلوا بقصف الاوكراني في دمشق حوالي 300
جنديات تم التعبئهم حديثا قضوا بالقصف
بينما تركهم القاده لمصيرهم وخرجت اصوات
النجيله منهم تشكو من الاخطاء الكارثيه في
الميدان الامر الذي استدعى ردا نادرا من
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اشهر ثمانيه عجاف مرت على القوات الروسيه
في اوكرانيا خسائر فادحه في الارواح
والعتاد وغضب شعبي استدعت كلها ردا نادرا
من وزاره الدفاع
تلقاها اللواء 55 بالقرب من منطقه
وسبعون جنديا نال عليهم قصف كثيف نجا منهم
130 وبقيت شهاداتهم تعكس المعانات
رايت رجالا يتمزقون امامي معظم وحدتنا
اختفت ودمرت كان جحيما وقادتنا تخلوا عنا
قبل بدء القصف بقليل
وجه الجنود رساله يشكون فيها حالهم
اسبوعان من التدريب لا يكفيان للزجي بنا
في الحرب وفي مدينه فارونيج الاستراتيجيه
القريبه من الحدود والتي ينتمي اليها
اغلبهاؤلاء تنام الغضب حتى بين مؤيد الحرب
مجموعات تتركو دون اتصال دون الاسلحه
اللازمه دون ادويه او دعم من المدفعيه
اتوبيت قادمه بالفعل
مستدعى ردا من وزاره الدفاع الروسي التي
كذبت روايه جنودها وقالت ان حجم الخسائر
في صفوفهم لم يتجاوز واحدا في المئه
ترجع صحيفه لموند الخسائر الروسيه الى
الضغط السياسي الثقيل على القياده
العسكريه لاحتلال المنطقه الاداريه
باكملها في دونيتسك التي ضمتها روسيا على
الورق في الثلاثين من سبتمبر بينما تسيطر
فعليا على نصفها فقط اضافه الى تكتيكات
باليه موروثه من ايام الجيش الاحمر ما
تزال تسيطر على القياده العليا الروسيه
والاهم زوج الجنود بالجبهات دون تدريب الى
جانب ضعف التنسيق بسبب تراجع مراكز
القياده لنحو 70 كلم عن خط الجبهه خوفا من
صواريخه مارس الامريكيه
تقول وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان معدل
الخسائر اليوميه للروس تضاعف الان ثلاث
مرات من 200 الى 600 جندي وهذا يعني انما
مجموعه
75,440 جنديا روسيا قتلوا منذ بدء الحرب
طبعا لا يمكن التحقق من دقه الارقام في ظل
حاله تعتيم الرسمي الروسي
لتبقى الحرب سجالا مفتوحا الى حين لكن
الاكيد انه مهما احتوى القياده الروسيه
ارقام جنودها القتلى فلن تستطيع احتواء
غضب الاهالي ماهر النبواني العربيه
معنا من كيف موفد العربيه هنسفيان وكذلك
من دونيس كمراسل العربيه رائد الاغربار
اهلا بكما ليبدا مع رغد اولا الوضع
الميدانيه راغد واين تتمركز هذه المعارك
ما بين القوات الاوكرانيه وكذلك
الانفصاليين الموالينا لروسيا
عادل نهاركم طيب ما زالت بالفعل المعارك
مستمره على المحورين الجنوبي والشرقي هنا
في اقليم تنباس تحديدا المقاطعه تتقدم
القوات المواليه لروسيا في المناطق
الشماليه الغربيه سيطره يوم امس على كامل
مطار دانيت ورفعت الكتائب المحليه هنا مثل
كتيبه عيسى عليه وسبارتا اعلامها على
مناطق مرتفعه في المطار كاشاره لاكمال
السيطره على هذه المنطقه كذلك في مدينه
مايورز سيطره القوات المواليه لروسيا على
مدينه
اهميه هذه المدينه الاستراتيجيه انها تفتح
الطريق للامدادات العسكريه لقوات التي
تقاتل في محور باقي
لا تعديده اخرها كانت همم بلده اوبتنا
ايضا سيطرت على بلده البرلمان خلف همم
مدينه بيسكي التي سيطر عليها الجيش الروسي
قبل اشهر اهميه هذه البلدات والمدن التي
سيطر عليها الانفصاليون في مقاطعه دانيت
تكمن في اكمال الطوق على المدن التي ماذا
لا يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني في هذه
المقاطعه ويطمح الجيش الروسي والانفصاليون
او الانفصاليا لاكمال السيطره على كامل
المقاطعه ايضا في المحور الجنوبي عادل
هناك جمال للقوات المواليه لروسيا على
مدينه اوغلودار التي تقع ما بين ظل نظافه
ومريوبل وتشير اوكرانيا الى انها تصد
الهجمات الروسيه همم هذا بخصوص المقاطعه
هنا مازال القصف مستمر ومتبادل ما بين
الطرف خاصه على اطراف مدينه اادانيس هناك
بشكل يومي قتلى وجرحى عند المدنيين طرف
المدنيين لكن ايه اذا سمح الوقت بعجال
محور خرسون همم منطقه سنيوركا حاولت
القوات الاوكرانيه الدخول الى مدينه خلصن
قلب المدينه التي تم اخلاؤها واجلاء
المدنيين منها تقول الدفاع الروسيه انها
احبطت هذا الهجوم شكرا جزيلا لرائد الاغبر
معنا كنت من دونسك الان نذهب الى هنصفيان
موفد العربيه من كيف هاني الاوضاع
الميدانيه وتحديدا همم ما هو رد اوكرانيا
على ما همم على هذه الانباء او هذا القصف
الروسي لها
هل من اصابات
اهلا بك اهلا بالزميل الرائد هناك طبعا
اولا سوف ابدا
بالتاكيدات الرسميه
والكعجل والتي اكدت من خلالها القوات
الاوكرانيه للعربيه طبعا تحدثت القوات
الاوكرانيه للعربيه قبل قليل او اكدت ان
القوات الروسيه سنه اكثر من اثنين وثلاثين
غاره جويه وكذلك اكثر من 70 هجوما عبر
راجمات الصواريخ تاثرت من خلالها اكثر من
35 بلده في محافظه
وكذلك اخر كيف هو ميكو لايف وكذلك ايضا
اكدت القوات الاوكرانيه العربيه القوات
الروسيه تقوم بانتهاك صارخ للقانون الدولي
والانساني من خلال استهدافها البنيه
التحتيه وكذلك منازل المواطنين في هذه
المحافظات طبعا هذا من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه التي اكدت لعربيه
كالمعلومات ايضا بالنسبه للعمليات المسجات
المسجدات والتي تحدث فيها اا الزميل
الرائد ايضا في الجانب الاوكراني قال نعم
ان هناك مواجهات حاميه وملتهبه في مناطق
كروسون وكذلك دونيتسكي وكذلك في نيكولايف
التي تواجه هذه الثلاثه محافظات معارك
ملتهبه همم يوم امس قالت القوات
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه اتخذت من
خرسون منطقه عسكريه وكذلك يجعلتها كمنطقه
عسكريه بالكامل واصبحت تستخدم المواطنين
بعمليه التهجير القسري وكذلك اصبحت القوات
الروسيه تتخفى
بالزي المدني وحولت هذه المنطقه من منطقه
من منطقه عسكريه الى حرب شوارع ايضا قالت
القوات الاوكرانيه اليوم للعربيه ان من
الجهه الشماليه من اوكرانيا بدات بلا
روسيا في نشر مشغلينها او للطائرات بدون
طيار وهذه يعني ان هناك استعداد لمعركه
جديده وقادمه من الجهه الشماليه لاوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا اللي موفد العربيه من كيف هاني
سفيان شكرا جزيلا لك
وصف رئيسه لجنه مجلس الاتحاد الروسي
للدفاع والامن فيكتور باندا ريف لشرو-
لشروط التي لشروطه التي طرحها الرئيس
الاوكرانيا للمفاوضات مع روسيا وصفها
بالسخيفه
وشدد بونداريف على ان عوده مناطق دوم بس
وخيرسون وزابولوجيا الى روسيا هي استعاده
لوحده اراضيها مؤكدا ان الاراضي الروسيه
في الاصل ولم يتم عزها بشكل غير قانوني
الا في التسعينيات وفق تعبيره في غضون ذلك
رفض الرئيس الاوكراني التفاوض مع الرئيس
الروسي بوتين قبل ان يسحب قوته من جميع
الاراضي الاخرانيه وقال زلنسكي ان روسيا
تسعى للتقدم الى ابعد ما بعد الى ما بعد
منطقه
لن نتنازل عن اي من المناطق الاوكرانيه
على الرغم من عوده الحديث عن امكانيه
استئناف المفاوضات المفاوضات بين روسيا
واوكرانيا بدعم من امريكي بهدف تقليل
مخاطر استخدام الاسلحه النوويه الا ان
التصريحات المتبادله بين موسكو وكيف لا
تنبا بامكانيات حدوث اختراق في المستقبل
المنظور
تهديداتي وتحذيرات على وقع الحرب في
اوكرانيا واشنطن فتحت نافذه الحوار مع
موسكو من اجل تقليد مخاطر استخدام محتمل
للاسلحه النوويه وافقاما كشفه مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جيك ساردا
سويسراليا
الاتص في الامور التي تتطلب ذلك وان روسيا
منفتحه على الحوارات المفيده للطرفين كياف
بدورها كانت قد وضعت شروطا للتفاوض مع
موسكو واهمها استعاده وحده الاراضي
واحترام ميثاق الامم المتحده والتعويض عن
جميع الاضرار التي سببتها الحرب ومعاقبته
كل مجرم حرب وضمانات لعدم تكرار ذلك
اوكرانيا ايدت الولايات المتحده بان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن ليس جادا في
الوقت الراهن بشان المفاوضات ما اثار
مخاوف عالميه ولكنه اقر بان رفض الرئيس
الاوكراني فولو دي ميرسي الدخول في
محادثات مع توتا اثار ايضا مخاوف في اجزاء
من اوروبا وافريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه وهي
المناطق التي ظهر فيها تاثير الحرب على
تكاليف الغذاء والوقود على نحو كبير تقول
صحيفه واشنطن بوست محاسن حضاره العربيه
[موسيقى]
وصل امين عمي مجلس الامن الروسي يا
نيكولايا باتري شيب الى طهران في زياره
جاءت تلبيه لدعوه نظيره الايراني علي
شمخاني لاجراء المشاورات حول مسائل امنيه
مع المسؤولين الايرانيين وهو وفقا لوسائل
اعلام ايرانيه ياتي ذلك في ظل اتهامات
الغربيه لايران بمساعده روسيا عسكريا في
اوكرانيا
نقلت رويترز عن هيئه البورصه الامريكيه
قولها ان رجل الاعمال الامريكي الى الماس
كاس يبيع 19 مليون سهم من شركه تسلا بقيمه
تصل الى اربعه ملايين دولار يذكر ان اسهم
شركه تسلا تراجعت اخيرا وخسرت النصف
قيمتها السوقيه بعد ان انتشرت تقارير
عمليه مسبقه لماسك لبيع اسهم
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
كوريا الجنوبيه تعلن اطلاق بيونغ يانغ
لصاروخان فالستين جديد قباله ساحلها
الشرقيه
حياكم الله اضرما محتجون النيران في صوره
للمرشد الايرانيه علي خامنئي في مدينه
يزدا وسط طهران وسطي ايران وذلك في الوقت
الذي تستمر الاحتجاجات ضد النظام وقمع
الشرطه في غضون ذلك دعان وشطاء للخروج في
مظاهرات بمناسبه مرور اربعين يوما على
مجزره زهدان التي راح ضحيتها 96 قتيلا
جراء المواجهات بين المحتجين وقوه الامن
علق ناشطون ايرانيون نازي طالبات المدارس
مخضبا باللون الاحمر كرمز للتلميذات
اللواتي قتلن في الاحتجاجات في شيراز
جنوبيه ايران
ابو نزار قاموس
ذلك فدت وسائل واعلام ايرانيه بمقتل احد
عناصر القوات الباسيج الايرانيه خلال
عمليه اعتقال محتاجين في جيلان شمالي
ايران قالت قناه العالم الايرانيه ان عنصر
الباسيج قتل خلال عمليه لالقاء القبض على
عناصر شغب خلت بامن المواطنين على حد
وصفها
من القاهره معنا محمد عباس ناجي رئيس
تحرير مجله مختارات ايراني يا سيد محمد
اهلا بك يعني اليوم نتحدث عن مقتل هذا
العنصر من الفرنسيج هل يعني ذلك شيئا في
تطورات المشهد الايراني
الضغوط التي تفرضها او يفرضها استمرار
للاحتجاجات الاحتجاجات وصلت الى اليوم 54
وبالتالي اقتربت من انهاء شهرها الثاني
وهذا معنان المحتجون في النهايه كسروا
حاجز الخوف وانهم مصرون على استمرار
الانتفاط في الشارع ومواجهه قوات الامن
والسلطات الايرانيه همم توجيه رساله لهذه
السلطات بانه ممارسه الاله القمعيه في
مواجهه المحتاجين لن تحقق نتائج كبيره على
غرار ما حدث في الاحتجاجات السابقه
وبالتالي لن تنجح في احتواء الاحتجاجات
خلال المرحله القادمه
طيب اليوم احنا نتحدث بعد هذه الفتره
الطويله هل توسع ودخول ربما مناطق جديده
في هذه الاحتجاجات يعطي زخما بان حتى لو
استخدمت ايران ميليشيات من الخارج تتبعها
قد لا تستطيع قمع هذه الاحتجاجات بل سترتد
عليها
بالطبع انا اتفق معك هذا سؤال مهم وانا
اتفق معك في انه استمرار استمرار النظام
على تبني الاله القمعيه بينتج في النهايه
تدعيات عكسيه والله لاحظنا احد اهم اسباب
استمرار الاحتجاجات حتى يومها الرابع
والخمسين هو العنف الذي يمارسه النظام بحق
المحتجين على مستوى قتل المحتاجين في
الشارع او اعتقال عدد كبير همم في همم
الاحتجاجات الحاليه وفرض قيود على شبكه
الانترنت طبعا هناك احتمال كبير بانه
بالفعل النظام يستقدم المليشيات من الخارج
لمساعدته على احتواء الاحتجاجات لكن
بالفعل كما قلت الاحتجاجات تطورت او تحول
همم تسعد افقيا وراثيا انتقلت من مجرد
الاحتجاج على مقتل فتاه همم كرديه الى
الاحتجاج او التمديد بالسياسات العامه
للنظام وانتقلت من مناطق الاكراد الى
العاصمه طهران والى بلوشستان والى
اذربيجان وغيره وبالتالي عامه مختلف انحاء
اا ايران خلال هذه الايام شكرا لي السيد
محمد عباس ناجي رئيس تحرير مجله مختارات
ايرانيه
اكد المرصد السوريه مقتل 15 من الميليشيات
المواليه لايران بقصف النفذتهم وسيارات
على الحدود السوريه العراقيه وذكر المرصد
ان الغارات التي وقعت في منطقه البوكمال
الحدوديه مع العراق في محافظه دير الزور
استهدفت شاحنات اسلحه وصهاريج مهرب
التطورات في الملف الاقتصادي دائما مع
نادين
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم
طبعا نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
لانه اي انقسام بين مجلس النواب او مجلس
الشيوخ يعتبر ايجابيا للاسواق لانه هذا
الجريد لوك بيخلي عدم تمرير السياسات اللي
بتعتبر متطرفه نوعا ما وخاصه نحن نعرف
سياسات الديمقراطيين مكلفه على الماليه
العامه وبالتالي هذا الانفاق الاضافي عاده
سلبي بمناخ فيه تضخم لانه يرفع من
المستويات التضخم لذلك الاسواق يوم امس
على ارتفعت تراقبا لنتيجه الانتخابات التي
تشير الى تقدم للجمهوريين للكونغرس
الامريكي هذه اغلاقات امريكا يوم امس على
ارتفاع وقت سندات الخزانه تراجعت الدولار
تراجع امام العملات الرئيسيه اذا هذه
الصوره العالميه التي الخلفيه اللي
تداولات اسواق من طاقتنا هذه الاسهم
المصريه كانت كلها على ارتفاع الاسواق
خلاص يا بيضه اليوم الصوره مختلفه لانه
بيانات صادرات من الصين كانت سلبيه حول
مؤشر اسعار المنتجين يدل على تراجع الطلب
بسبب سياسه صفر». وهذا اثر سلبا على
الاسهم الصينيات هذه هذه اسعار العملات عم
نشوف اليورو فوق الباريتي مع الدولار
والباوند فوق ال 1.15 امام الدولار اسعار
النفط متماسكه على 95 دولار مزيج برنس
للقناطر على اسواق من طاقتنا لاداؤها
متباين في ظل هذه الخلفيه العالميه السوق
السعوديه على بعض تراجع دبي ايضا ولكن ابو
ظبي نتائج ايجابيه من شركات تدعم بعض
الشيء مؤشر السوق والكويت عندنا ارتفاع
سريعه على ابرز الاسهم القياديه بكل من
هذه الاصوات لحتى نشوف ما الذي يحرك هذه
التداولات عن مجموعه من نتائج الشركات
السعوديه هذه الاسهم الاكثر تداولا حتى
الساعه الحفر العربيه راجحي على تراجع
اليوم لانها مرتفع وسابك للمغنيات
الزراعيه صفقه على تراجع باسنان بالمئه
هذا في السعوديه اما في نتائج شركات العمل
تبعها البحر الاحمر كان عندها خساره اربع
خساره والسهم يتراجع بالسته بالمئه العبد
اللط النهارده تراجع بالارباح عذرا كان
عندها خساره 15.6 مليون ريال بربع تالنت
تسعه للخساره عن الربع الثالث من العام
الماضي وسهم تراجع العربيه اللي تعهدات
الفنيه الصوره مختلفه كان عندها
النتائج الرابعه الثالثه ارتفاع 15.4 الى
66 مليون ريال لذلك السهم على ارتفاع ب 2%
انا اكتفي بهذا القدر للسعوديه خلينا نشوف
لها همم سوق اخرى نشوف ما الذي يحرك
الاسواق بشكل سريع فاذن عنا بابو ظبي
مجموعه من نتائج الشركات كما ذكرت اتت
قويه همم هذا سوق دبي على بعض تراجع عشان
بدنا نفطر اليوم مع تراجع بسلس النقطه
المئويه ولكن دبي الاسلامي على ارتفاع ابو
ظبي الارتفاع على صعيد مؤشر السوق نتائج
قويه جدا العالميه القابضه وسهمها على
ارتفاع بثلاث ارباع النقطه المئويه سنكتفي
بهذا القدر القاكم بعد قليل المشاهدين في
الاسواق العربيه عوده الان الى عادل
[موسيقى]
شكرا يا دينا قال الجيش وكوريا الجنوبيه
النا كوريا الشماليه الطاقه الصاروخان
قبالتها الشرقيه وهذا الاطلاق هو الاحدث
في عام قياسيه من التجارب الصاروخيه التي
اجرتها كوريا الشماليه في وقت تتزايد
المخاوف من
قد تستعدوا لاول اختبار النيل جهاز النووي
منذ عام 2017
مقاتلات عاصفه اليقظه الاكثر تطورا في
العالم تكشف ازمه سلاح الجو في كوريا
الشماليه
استعراض عسكريين المتقدم حلق الطيران
الامريكيون والكوريون الجنوبيون في
المناوراتهم المشتركه في مقاتلات اكثر تي
5 الخفيه المتطوره و طائرات حربيه
الكترونيه وطائرات اخرى لتزويد الوقود
مناورات المتقدمه دفعت للتساؤل عن حادث
سلاح الجو لدى كوريا الشماليه لتتحدث
تقارير عسكريه عن تهالك سلاح الجو لكوريا
الشماليه وبانه الحلقه الاضعف في جيشها
لعده اسباب
يمتلك سلاح الجو لكوريا الشماليه 900
طائره مقاتله و 300 طائره شحن و 300
مروحيه وفقا لوكاله استخبارات الدفاع
الامريكيه حصلت عليها من الصين او الاتحاد
السوفيتي سابقا معظم تلك المقاتلات متوقف
في العنابر وخارج الخدمه
تقارير لوكاله استخبارات الدفاع الامريكيه
ذكرت ان كوريا الشماليه ليست لديها قدرته
على دفع ما يكفي من الوقود او تغطيه
تكاليف الصيانه او تدريب الطيارين بشكل
صحيح فالطيارون يحلقون ما بين 15 الى 25
ساعه طيران سنويا اي اقل بكثير من المتوسط
المعروف في صفوف القوات الجويه والكوريه
الجنوبيه
ايضا ان السبب تاخر السلاح الجو الكوري
الشمالي كان وراءه انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي الذي كان مصدر رئيسا للدعم
المالي والعسكري فضلا عن العقوبات التي
فرضت على كوريا الشماليه بسبب برامجها
لانتاج الصواريخ والاسلحه النوويه ما زاد
من صعوبه ايجاد موارد لتطوير وتحديث
سلاحها ملوك الشيخ العربي
[موسيقى]
نهايه النشره تفكير بابرز العناوين
هذا انتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه تقدم
جمهوري بمجلس النواب ومنافسه حاده على
مجلس الشيوخ
يتعهدوا بالسعاده دونتسكون انفصاليو
اوكرانيا يتحدثون عن معارك عنيفه في
نيكولايب
مجزره زاهدان ومقتل العنصر في الباسيج
خلال عمليه اعتقال محتجين
المرصد السوري يعلن مقتل 15 عنصرا من
ميليشيا مواليه لايران في قصف بشرق سوريا
اترككم في رعايه الله وحظه